[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we called it the traveler and its
arrival changed us forever great cities
were built on Mars and Venus mercury
became a garden world human lifespan
tripled it was a time of miracles we
stared out at the galaxy and knew that
it was our destiny to walk in the light
of other stars but the traveller had an
enemy a darkness which had hunted it for
eons across the black gulfs of space
centuries after our Golden Age began
this darkness found us
and that was the end of everything
that is until I found you
[Music]
we've always known the darkness would
return
[Music]
to finish what it started
to take our home
that's why I've been looking for you for
centuries there are only a few of you
who carry the light of the traveler who
have the strength to fight the darkness
I'm not going to lie to you Guardian you
are Earth's last hope
[Music]
if you fail
everything humans have and
[Music]
forever
[Applause]
[Music]
no pressure
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Andrew house
[Music]
good evening how we doing
thank you for being here tonight and
thanks to the millions of people
watching live across the world it was
only a year ago that I was on this very
stage to introduce PlayStation 4 and
share our vision for the future of
gaming and entertainment our vision is
grounded in an uncompromising commitment
to gamers that ensures PlayStation is
above all else the best place to play
and we know what best means it means
connected it means the highest visual
quality
it means choice and it means not being a
lone gamer but a member of an extensive
community of rivals and friends the
destiny trailer that kicked off
tonight's show is the embodiment of our
vision from its graphic fidelity to its
dynamic social experiences - it's deeply
immersive gameplay destiny will help
define this next generation of gaming
like so many of the world's biggest and
best games you'll be able to play
destiny first on PlayStation
millions around the world have been
eagerly awaiting the Destiny baton
tonight I'm excited to announce that
PlayStation gamers will get their hands
on it first
starting July 17th and for those
PlayStation fans who can't wait until
next month for the beta to start we've
got something extra special for ps4
starting this Thursday and lasting
through the weekend ps4 owners around
the world will get a chance to play the
destiny first look alpha visit the
website behind me
he says hoping it's there to be a part
of the first gameplay experience that it
is only available on ps4 but destiny
isn't just first on PlayStation it's
better in addition to all of the extra
content that only PlayStation customers
will receive I'm happy to announce our
first ever white PlayStation 4 that
comes
[Applause]
with an exclusive destiny bundle that
we'll make available when the game
releases on September 9th the bundle
includes a 500 gigabyte glacier white
ps4 a white jewel shop for the game and
a 30-day voucher for Pierce for
PlayStation Plus thank you to our
friends at Bungie and Activision destiny
looks stunning on ps4 and I know you're
going to love playing it on PlayStation
destiny is just the tip of the iceberg
in looking at all of the PlayStation 4
games that we'll show tonight that are
either exclusive to ps4 look better
feature exclusive content all the
ability to pay it before any other
platform let's now take a look at
another new IP that will be available
only on PlayStation 4
[Applause]
[Music]
arena commander powers have in the
basement procedure precaution
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a busy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll fix the loafers a small team made
up entirely of recent graduates from to
academic gaming programs Carnegie
Mellon's entertainment Technology Center
and the San Jose State University
animation and illustration program we're
here to show you our first game entwined
it's a game about two souls who are in
love but can't be together and here
helping me done with the game of some of
the other talented members of the pixel
opus team
[Music]
and twine features a new twist on dual
SIM control that revolves around
learning to guide two characters at once
one with each analog stick and as you
play you must negotiate addictive
sequences of obstacles that grow in
complexity and speed over the course of
nine unique lifetimes you'll have to
bring these characters together and when
you do they'll transform into an
incredible dragon
[Music]
each lifetime draws to a close with your
dragon blazing a trail across the sky
with living paint and unless you create
your own aerial sculpture
[Music]
and twine is a unique gameplay
experience and our team really hopes
that you'll enjoy it thank you thank God
that looks great
hi everybody I'm Scott rody head of
worldwide studios for North America
thank you if you couldn't tell I
absolutely love this game and I'm really
excited for that young team
it's a beautiful mesmerizing experience
and here's the best part you guys will
not have to wait to get your hands on
entwined the ps4 version is available
right now in the PlayStation Store for
$9.99 with ps3 and Vita to follow as
part of our cross-buy program you can
even pull up your PlayStation app on
your phone right now and order it and
it'll be waiting for you when you get
home so just as entwined surrounds you
in beauty and mystique the world of
infamous second son immersed you in a
visual spectacle and raise the bar on
groundbreaking performance capture the
team of sucker punch has been developing
a new piece of standalone DLC that will
be available later this summer you don't
need the own second son to play the DLC
but if you do you'll get some exclusive
content please let's take a look
[Music]
I know
or you can imagine
but I can't help you I love you
OpenOffice
[Music]
please tell me what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
hello
I'm Pete Smith and I'm here today to
show you a little big planet for the
first time on PlayStation 4 since that
boy gear back and he's very pleased to
be here and I'm gonna take you through
this level and show you some of the cool
new features we've got in the game for
the first thing you'll notice is that
we've got much more depth than we've
ever had in the day before I'm now going
to collect one of the many new power-ups
that start by having the game this one's
called the pump and aether and it can
put there and I can use it to pump this
wheel and reveal a completely new
friends force at boy this is also high
I'm not suck and what makes me different
to that point well for starters I'm I
can will jump yes I can guys I can keep
going guys keep attention
I'm also much faster than stat point and
I can use my SuperSpeed to power things
in a little big planet world and in to
keep juice you guys to a new frame
called Pagal everyone this is toggle as
you can see toggle is the biggest of
suck boys new friends how about being
the biggest it's also the strongest so
come on guys I'm gonna push this really
happy block and let you follow me
through thank you
come on slack boy okay so it's well
being the biggest new character tarball
can also become the smallest at the top
of a button and fit through small gaps
like this now going to turn back the
heavy toggle and reveal another new
character called sweet hey everyone I'm
swoop
woohoo so although all of the new
characters got fantastic great new
abilities whatnot of them like can fly
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
so in there we go okay now this last
section
toggle can go down and pull this and let
us through
brilliant panel of some boy I'll use the
company to return the favor and then we
can all get into the rocket and we can
blast off out at the level mogul if that
you're going to need to go heavy weld on
everyone rubs off
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you everyone we're going to go
we'll leave you with a little bit more
of LittleBigPlanet on PlayStation 4
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
thank you
I hope you enjoyed the demo
LittleBigPlanet 3 the creative community
of LittleBigPlanet has been very active
and by today over 8.7 million levels
have been created and shared by the
community on LittleBigPlanet and
LittleBigPlanet - and I'm very happy to
announce that when LBP three launches
you can just go online and play any of
this vast catalog of user-generated
levels on LVP 3 with improved graphics
on ps4 it's going to be great fun for
the whole family this Christmas but
LittleBigPlanet 3 is just one of the
great variety of titles that our
worldwide studios teams are developing
for ps4 and tonight I get the honor of
introducing a completely new IP from one
of the industry's most respected games
will game directors this is a project
that is very dear to my heart if you
know me and our history with the
developer welcome to the world of
blood-borne
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
creative director of Fock right for our
goal with FARC rise to create beautiful
exotic and dangerous locations fill them
with weapons vehicles and toys and let
you create your own story this year with
far cry 4 we invite you to visit current
a country soaked in secret history
filled with weaponized animals and ruled
by an eccentric despot good luck
[Music]
AJ the porters you're looking for is
called rat daddy should be the dolly
down below okay I'll head in that
direction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is a five-minute rule
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
we need some help taking this place down
Herc back me up
someone call for a cub skirt a
gyrocopter
[Music]
all right
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Adam
boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it's pretty great I've never get a
mauled a ton in by Tigers in Far Cry 3
so I really look forward to getting a
revenge in the Himalayan mountains with
a weaponized pachyderm I mean come on
you know this November when you buy Far
Cry 4 on either ps3 or ps4 you can
invite your PSN friends to join you even
if they don't own the game yeah and
you'll only be able to do that on
PlayStation
[Applause]
through social mediums like Twitter and
Facebook or forums like Reddit and
neogaf we are constantly connected to
you the gamers all around the world and
we love hearing from you directly
recently we invited you to send us in
some letters about how you feel a
Playstation and what kinds of games you
want to see in the future let's check
out some of those letters that you
shared with us a common theme that you
guys wrote in about with zombies I mean
who doesn't love us some zombie action
let's see what's been festering in the
undead Department
nobody
I got my drugs and my Dickies and I put
it on
bang
[Music]
Barney and the two for the show
the catch me and if you wanna train
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
seriously sweet time is plate freakin
awesome let's go
[Applause]
kind of gives a whole new meaning to the
term fresh kicks right at PlayStation we
love us some shambling goodness whether
it's zombies walkers are the infected
most of you know the last of us is
coming to ps4 yeah but what you didn't
know is that it's also going to be
infecting Diablo 3 in the ultimate evil
edition launching August 19 yes you'll
be able to battle clickers bloaters and
stalkers in an exclusive themed dungeon
and Blizzard has integrated them deeply
into the game so they have their own
special attacks I seriously cannot wait
to play adventure mode now many of you
also wrote in and thanked us for
bringing some benefits on PlayStation
and Lea we loved nothing more than
trying new things and bringing new
opportunities to you the PlayStation
nation before anybody else now you just
saw a Dead Island to debut it will have
a 30 day exclusive beta as well as a
full exclusive character class level
only on ps4 and earlier today we're part
of EA's announcement of a special beta
for battlefield hardline it's available
right now exclusively for consoles on
ps4 battlefield hardline takes the
cops-and-robbers fantasy we all played
when we were kids but then it goes to a
whole new level with awesome action
stunning visuals and a grappling hook
come on now let's take a look at an
exclusive new world premiere gameplay
trailer for battlefield hardline Sky 5
can confirm a large police presence in
downtown Los Angeles
all units we have confirmation that a
211 is underway no charge is good
[Music]
suspects are coming with the package
take him down
[Music]
all right we're good to go on the ground
[Music]
[Music]
you have the right to remain silent
[Music]
grappling hooks and zip lines that is my
jam and you know play it first isn't
limited just Tomatoes we're happy to
announce a new partnership with Disney
which will bring exclusive content to
our platform this year the only place
you can Hulk smash in Disney infinity 2
at launch will be on PlayStation
platforms The Incredible Hulk will join
five other Avengers in this exclusive
Disney infinity to collector's edition
for ps3 and ps4 pretty cool
and finally as Andy mentioned earlier
there's always going to be more of
destiny on PlayStation on launch day
you're gonna get an incredible amount of
exclusive in-game content from unique
weapons armor sets gear kick-ass ships
as well as Exodus an exclusive
competitive multiplayer map and the best
part an entire exclusive strike on Mars
strikes are standalone unique co-op
opportunity or co-op adventures we get
to battle epic bosses there's literally
too much great content to detail tonight
but needless to say when destiny comes
to PlayStation this year it will do so
first bigger and better than on any
other platform
Hulk smash is right
now a lot of you asked for brand new
things that you've never seen on the
platform before this next partner is a
great example of that I'm proud to
announce a new partnership with Paradox
Interactive every single paradox to do
is currently working on an exclusive
PlayStation 4 game and here's a look at
their first one paradox is proud to
present user created
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shikaku learn to spell
yeah
[Music]
I think I know how to spell pretty well
I'm pretty sure that's not how you spell
Magica but just saying of all the
thousands of letters we received there
was some kind of special anot about this
next one can do anything can it do
miracles I'm only 12 years old so I was
not alive and some of the best games
ever made came out now a lot of them are
gone forever the player masterpiece like
for instance one of Tim Schafer's old
adventure games I would have to pirate
it and that's not nice
these is there anything you can do to
bring great games like one of Tim
Schafer's back from the dead
sincerely Sally th10 I think somebody's
throwing me okay so she was 12 at first
now she's 10 there's a fingerprint let's
move that over that's got knucklehead I
think that's the 10 or 12 year old let's
pan it up a bit that's not a 12 year
olds beard okay bring it all the way out
that's tin mother woman Schaefer okay
Sally all right we have some great news
for you and the fans after 15 years
double firing in tandem with our third
party production team will be
remastering your classic adventure game
Grim Fandango
[Applause]
[Music]
it will be coming exclusively to both
ps4 and PSVita thanks to the
relationship with our good friends at
Disney looks like it's time again to
work Sally maybe something a little
shave
Sally Tim Sally Sally you've also told
us you guys love a wide range of crazy
and diverse games this next partner
shares our love and support of
independent independent developers and
has brought fantastic games and
fantastic games to play station like
Vlambeer luftrausers
and den attends hotline Miami devolver
digital and their main man fort Parker
have been working on an awesome slate of
new titles and we've officially joined
forces all of the following titles
you're about to see will be making their
console debut exclusively on PlayStation
platforms
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I wonder will you love us for having
created you will the world you build be
like ours or so different that we today
cannot even imagine it your will is free
because you were made to be free
let you will be done you know what after
watching the likes of Robocop and bronan
the bro bearing and broforce I can't
help but bro out all of our playstation
names
we've got Andrew bro house Scott Brody
bro hey bro cheetah right okay I'll move
yea I'll move along so here's another
letter that we got that I really liked
every time I play a game I get to
experience the imagination of an artist
and you'll never know where that will
take you this is absolutely true the
breath of incredibly creative and
original games regularly astounds me one
Creator who has always pushed artistic
boundaries in gaming with inspired
stories and offbeat worlds is suda51 and
his next twisted trip is only coming to
PlayStation 4 let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
video games right you know that game
doesn't remind me of journey journey
took us on an incredible adventure in
part thanks to Matt Navas stunning art
direction and composer Austin winter
ease Grammy nominated score they're
teaming up again at Matt's new studio
giant squid let's see the world premiere
of their brand-new game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful an absence of console debut on
ps4 just look at the staggering range of
content coming to PlayStation Network
all of it pushing creativity and
innovation thanks to all the developers
for bringing your amazing games to
PlayStation it means a ton to us thank
you for the letters and thanks to all of
our fans for loving games the same way
we do I can't believe I get to do this
every single day please keep the
feedback coming we're always listening
our goal of PlayStation is pretty simple
to surprise and amaze you and we're just
getting started so I'm gonna leave you
guys with one last game that surprised
and amazed me and will make its console
debut on ps4 please enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you feel like a lot of emotions
right now
I'm Shawn I'm from hello games we're a
tiny little indie studio we're a group
of friends making no man sky it's a
science fiction game I guess inspired by
the kind of sci-fi that I grew up with
the battered book covers of Heinlein
Asimov Clark just worlds that I wanted
to escape to but never could we've
created a procedural universe it's
infinite and it's one that everyone can
share we're going to start every player
on a different planet so no two people
will have the same experience this
universe that we've created it's it's so
vast it's so boundless it's actually
infinite and we don't even know what's
out there when the game releases every
player who picks up a pad and plays is
going to help us discover a little bit
more and I can't wait I want to finish
with just a tiny taste of what your own
unique journey into infinity might look
like hope you like it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
my slightly blown thank you very much
Sean and thanks to Adam a key focus for
tonight has been demonstrating why
PlayStation delivers the best place to
play today and in the future you've seen
that in the diverse portfolio of games
coming from our worldwide studios and
our close partners and we're also
bringing this to life in new ways with
hardware when we design ps4 we made a
conscious decision to make it the most
powerful gaming console ever created and
surround it with breakthrough games
features network capabilities and
peripherals that together would redefine
next-gen gaming a key peripheral that
we've offered to ps4 gamers since launch
as a choice is the PlayStation camera
we believe that the playstation camera
would be a popular option because of the
value it provides for more immersive
gaming but the responses far exceeded
our expectations and we're enhancing the
value of the playstation camera what it
brings to ps4 by pursuing new innovative
technology that takes gaming to an
entirely new dimension at GDC in March
we unveiled project Morpheus which
demonstrates how we are fully leveraging
the power of the PlayStation camera the
response from the development community
and gamers was phenomenal all of your
voices have been heard and today there
are creative teams around the world
working with us to define the future of
gaming and entertainment we have project
Morpheus in our booth at e3 this year
with two new demos so I encourage all of
you to stop by and try it
up next is someone who has a 15 year
history at Playstation that includes
eight years at worldwide studios in
London and he also served as president
of Sony Computer Entertainment Japan I
personally known him for more than 20
years and when I think of the game
behind me I can't help but think of him
he was most recently the CEO of Sony
network entertainment and now as
president and CEO of Sony Computer
Entertainment America
he's charged with quite simply making
sure PlayStation completely surpasses
your wildest expectations please join me
in giving a warm welcome to Shawn Layden
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Andy and thank and thanks to
all of you for the for the really warm
welcome out here on stage wow there's a
lot of people in this room
I've been to every three except the very
first one from Atlanta from LA to
Atlanta then back to LA I've sat where
all of you are sitting now but never
thought for a second that I might have
the honor and privilege of being on this
stage before all of you and well it is a
great honor to be here I got to say the
strongest emotion I'm feeling right now
is excitement and more than a little
pressure but I'm completely and utterly
thrilled to be here as you've witnessed
already the thirst for innovation at
Playstation is tremendous
our lineup of genre and blockbusting
titles is a testament to that and our
desire to bring great games to all of
you is matched by our commitment to
bring a great gaming experience
throughout the world of PlayStation so
let's start by talking about PSN
our network is robust and ever-evolving
to deliver the experience gamers want
and we have heard loud and clear what
you're looking for powerful ways in
which to share your experiences and
connect with your friends and the
growing PlayStation community to that
end we continue to bring new tools to
the ps4 faithful to enable that desire
for shared experience such as share
factory and the photo mode and second
son and we'll continue to enhance our
features that redefine how when and
where gamers play a quick look at that
reality is frankly awesome nearly 95% of
ps4's worldwide are connected to the
network and the social activity is
astounding more than one and a quarter
billion hours have been spent gaming
more than 1 billion multiplayer sessions
have been played on ps4 since launch
that's a lot of deathmatch the share
button on the DualShock floor has been
pressed 220 million times as gamers
invite friends and the community to
check out their gameplay and that last
metric will climb even higher when we
bring YouTube to ps4 later this year
with the simple press of the DualShock
for share button ps4 gamers will be able
to quickly upload video captures to
their YouTube channel you will also be
able to see your friends shared YouTube
videos in your what's new Activity Feed
ps4 is also the first console to allow
you to live broadcast and spectate game
sessions already more than 150 million
spectate sessions have been viewed on
ps4 and we're constantly innovating this
experience as well look when you're
watching at home some schlock horror
movie some times haven't you felt the
need to or the desire to scream at the
television screen look out behind you or
don't open that door well now only on
ps4 you can effectively do just that
while spectating and they will get the
message not only can you watch someone's
gameplay in real time you can now
interact with that person's game
experience while they're playing you can
help them
you can harm them it's up to you but
you're right there with them this is
another way we're going to redefine what
social gaming can really mean this
summer we will further enhance ps4 s
broadcasting capabilities with some new
content for the playroom the free DLC
will allow you to easily create your own
custom broadcasting sets so you can
further personalize your message and
content for the Widing gamer wider gamer
community never losing sight of what has
always made PlayStation great we're
using the network to bring you more of
what you want awesome gaming experiences
games that are epic and challenging and
games that are more accessible such as
free to play we're committed to making a
Playstation the best destination for
free-to-play games
free-to-play offers a great way to
discover new worlds and experiences and
we think this category will explode on
PlayStation in the coming years right
now we have more than 25 free-to-play
games coming to ps4 in the next 12
months including Kingdom under fire -
from blue side planetside 2 from Sony
Online Entertainment there you go and
guns up from Valkyrie entertainment and
on PlayStation at point of entry
free-to-play means free to play let's
take a look at that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
free-to-play what more do I have to say
there you go we just talked about ease
of entry and the joy of discovery and a
Playstation we continue to develop and
innovate simple ways to access content
PlayStation now fueled by the power of
the network will provide our community
with access to our massive gaming
libraries starting with PlayStation 3
titles we have continued to tweak and
refined PS now since its initial beta
test and are proud to announce that the
service will be available in the United
States and Canada as an open beta on ps4
starting July 31st shortly after that PS
now will become available on ps3 and
PlayStation Vita as well we also we also
want to unlock our library of games to
those who still don't own a Playstation
device so later this year we're bringing
the PlayStation now experience to select
Sony televisions if PS now is available
in your area all you need to do is get a
dual shock 3 and you're able to play our
vast catalogue of games
yeah that's pretty
during the open beta PlayStation gamers
will have access to more than 100 ps3
games from the industry's best
publishers our own worldwide studios as
well as the best of the indie
development community in our booth at e3
this week you can play such major hits
as Dead Space 3 God of War ascension
middle Gear Solid 5 Ground zeroes
Ratchet and Clank into the Nexus and
Ultra Street Fighter 4 will use the open
beta continue to listen to your feedback
and gather insights about your
experience with the service will also
work with our publishing partners to
test a range of rental durations and
prices we do look forward to hearing
from everyone who participates in the
beta as your voice will have a direct
impact on the development of our service
bringing PlayStation now to PlayStation
Vita is another example of our
commitment to the platform with PS now
Vita will have the best catalog of games
available on a mobile device and the
only mobile device with access to the
deep library of PlayStation games
innovation on Vita continues and its
integration with PlayStation 4 has
expanded the way gamers use the device
Remote Play gives Vita owners quick
access to ps4 games and the response has
been overwhelmingly positive with remote
play ps4 blockbusters such as Call of
Duty and Assassin's Creed will further
showcase PlayStation Vita as the
ultimate mobile platform in total there
are more than 100 Vita titles in
development today including tales of
hearts are from Namco
[Music]
ubisoft's beautifully hand-drawn RPG
child of light and Telltale's mash-up
with gearbox tales and borderlands
minecraft is also coming to Vita and it
will be the full console experience with
co-op included you got two minecraft
bank PSV that will remain a key pillar
for us and we look forward to sharing
more gaming experience across Vita
dedicated titles PlayStation now and ps4
remote play a Tokyo Game Show last year
we announced another new console and the
outpouring of anticipation and
excitement was unprecedented as a result
we are now preparing to launch that
product in the United States Canada and
Europe starting this fall so let's talk
about PlayStation TV
this little gem will be able to pair
with your PlayStation 4 allowing you to
play your ps4 game via remote play on a
second television in your home it will
give you access to video and music
streaming services will give you the
ability to play hundreds of ps3 titles
made available through PlayStation now
and of course PlayStation TV will also
play most Vita titles as well as ps1 and
PSP classics in fact our Disney
partnership continues with Disney
infinity 2 coming to PlayStation TV and
PlayStation Vita early next year in
total that's nearly 1,000 games that
PlayStation TV owners will have access
to at launch PlayStation TV will be
available for $99 we will also offer a
bundle for $139 that will include a dual
shock 3 an 8 gigabyte memory card an
HDMI cable and a digital voucher for the
lego movie video game
new games new hardware new network
services the pace of innovation and
PlayStation continues to accelerate and
as our world expands we will stay true
to our roots to create imaginative games
that foster fun while pioneering new
gaming concepts little earlier I was
delighted to hear Andy give a shout-out
to one of the most iconic games of our
time vid Riven yeah give it up a big
brother a personal favorite of mine that
really embodies the Playstations spirit
it wasn't a multi-million seller but
that's not the point
VIP ribbon was unafraid to go against
the tide it was courageous in its
ambition and it brought a completely new
experience to gamers it's an incredible
time to be part of the PlayStation
family I look forward to growing our
gaming community through breakthrough
experiences that inspire and delight
after all guys it's all about the games
isn't it
and speaking of games in 1996 I got my
start at PlayStation in Japan importing
and localizing games from the US and
Europe for the Japanese market that's
kind of like trying to import wine into
Napa Valley but one of the first games
we localized was Mortal Kombat 3 on ps1
the game that introduced the concept of
fatality to the Japanese gamer that's
why it's a tremendous pleasure and a
unique thrill for me to introduce on
this stage the worldwide premiere of
gameplay footage for Mortal Kombat X
[Applause]
murderer
Mike tire of maintaining our innocence
I believe you about where you offend
this one for what ladybug do about it
exterminate sound
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beat
[Music]
[Applause]
really what can you say thanks Sean
a Playstation we know building a
portfolio of incredible games is
paramount but we also know that ps4
owners are using the console extensively
for watching their favorite movies TV
shows and listening to music
millions of ps4 owners are using the
likes of Netflix Amazon Instant Video
Hulu Plus and music unlimited and our
entertainment offering on ps4 is about
to take a new superhero twist Sony is
one of the largest entertainment brands
in the world and we're fully utilizing
its vast resources to bring new
experiences and more value to ps4 last
year Michael Lynton joined us on stage
to announce that Sony Pictures
Entertainment is developing brand-new
original programming available
exclusively on ps4 and the network and
we're not just bringing any new content
to our platform in line with our focus
on the highest quality entertainment
experiences we're developing and
curating content that is tailored
specifically to what gamers loved most
our first original series is called
powers and is based on the critically
acclaimed graphic novel series thank you
of the same name created by Brian
Michael Bendis and Michael Avon oming in
addition to powers I know many of you
are familiar with Brian's work with
Marvel as he is one of the highest
selling Marvel comic writers ever he
also sits on the Marvel creative
committee and has consulted on every
Marvel movie since Iron Man please join
me in giving a great PlayStation welcome
to powers co creator and executive
producer for the series Brian Michael
Bendis
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Andy hello playstation nation
it is an honor to be here personally and
we are so excited to officially announce
to you that powers has been greenlit to
series from Sony television and
Playstation thank you for those of you
don't know what powers is powers is
based on the comic book and graphic
novel series of the same name created by
myself in artist Michael Avon oming and
it tells the story of Christian Walker
and Deena pilgrim two homicide
detectives that work cases specifically
about powers that means if the greatest
superhero in the world suddenly falls
dead from the sky if the one of the most
notorious super villains of all time is
found dead in a gutter that's their case
and Walker Christian Walker has a secret
he used to be a power but now he's down
here with us having lost his powers and
it is his job to answer for those who
cannot answer for themselves the dead
powers of our universe some of these
cases will be some of his oldest friends
some of these cases will be his
longest-running enemies but every case
is going to show us something new about
our characters is going to show us
something about what we've developed in
the comic which is a pretty sprawling
mythology about superheroes and it's
also going to show us what a world with
superheroes would really be like how we
would really treat them how they would
immerse our culture how they would
affect our fashion and we're just
immensely proud of it and we're
immensely proud that we're here today to
bring it to your television now I I'm
I'm a gamer I'm a game writer and I know
that gamers and comic book lovers we
love our genre hardcore we love our
genres to mash up and to show us
something new to show us something
original and one of my jobs as executive
producer of the show is to make sure
that the TV show gives us what the comic
book gave us that it has all the
integrity and everything that we've
built all there with all the
authenticity that we can muster now the
good
we have this great team behind the
scenes our showrunner is award-winning
novelist Charlie Houston our executive
producer is Remy o Bhushan from falling
skies in Caprica
an other executive producer is David
angle from circled confusion and they
brought us to walking dead now this
relieves me to no end that this will be
the powers that I want to see on TV that
hopefully is the powers that you want to
see on TV as we speak we're in
production casting is underway and all
summer long we're going to have all
kinds of announcements and teases and
all kinds of stuff for you online but
just to give you something for today
let's show you some brand-new concept
art that just came from our concept
artist and I think it shows you just a
little taste of what we're going to have
which is like everything I love about
you know gritty crime fiction and
spectacular superheroes mashed up
together for something completely new on
behalf of Michael Avon oming and the
producers and everyone working on the
show the writers I want to thank Sony
television I want to thank Playstation
and thank all of you who have been so
vocal in your support of the book for
all these years and the idea of a TV
show we're coming to you on PlayStation
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks Bryan PlayStation 4 owners won't
have to wait long for powers I'm happy
to announce that it will be available in
the US in December we want to make sure
that as many PlayStation fans as
possible get an opportunity to
experience our vision for original
content so every PSN user in the US will
get to watch the first episode of powers
for free as you're aware we're
constantly bringing more value to the
PlayStation Plus subscription service
today this comes in the form of
discounted games early access to beta
programs and the instant game collection
which has resulted in a hundred and
ninety percent increase in global plus
subscribers since the ps4 launch we'll
be adding more value to Plus in the
future by including our original
programming I'm pleased to announce that
all plus subscribers in the US will be
able to view the entire powers series
for free
in addition to original content we're
also leveraging worldwide studios
well-loved franchises and Sony's family
of media channels to bring new
theatrical content to existing
PlayStation fans and entirely new
audiences here's a look at Ratchet and
Clank the movie I've always dreamt of
being a galactic Ranger doing big things
like captain quark you don't have what
it takes
wait just give me a chance all right no
time galaxy and jeopardy get back out
there and remember you can do anything
as long as you're meat
[Music]
oh that was it close one huh yeah that
is gonna show up on that nadir review
[Music]
Ratchet and Clank creator insomniac
games is heavily involved in the film
and we're also working with the studio
to reimagine the original Ratchet and
Clank for ps4 the game will feature
completely new visuals and gameplay
sequences that will rival the best ps4
games on the market both the movie and
game will be available in the first half
of 2015 and will continue to release
exclusive content and titles only
available on PlayStation there are
nothing short of amazing
we announced in April that The Last of
Us a game that won more than 200 Game of
the Year awards last year is being
remastered for ps4 let's see what's in
store
[Music]
[Music]
the
it's a mess from
[Music]
[Applause]
and
from the sea
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
as you've seen tonight we have the
industry's best developers creating
games for ps4 right now and there's more
a long-standing partnership with Kojima
Productions and Konami
has been a staple of the PlayStation
history today it is my pleasure to
introduce a new trailer that some of you
might have gotten a sneak peek of last
night ladies and gentlemen
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
[Music]
[Applause]
standing on the edge
of the crater like the prophets once
said
and the ashes are all core now no more
bullets I members are dead
whisperer
[Music]
tell the tales of the brothers go
desolation devastation
[Applause]
what a mess we made
put it all went wrong
watch in
from the air
ah the circus for the games to begin
gladiator
draw that sort
[Music]
standing
[Applause]
[Music]
looking at the abyss
[Music]
to escape from
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Metal Gear Solid 5 on ps4 is going to be
amazing and now let's take a look at
something from a company that I've had a
personal relationship with since the ps2
era their games have cat placed in
PlayStation gamers up late at night for
generations as they pioneered new genres
and new experiences
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm thrilled to announce that grand
theft auto 5 is coming to PlayStation 4
this fall grand theft auto 5 takes full
advantage of the power of PS 4 and
features a host of enhancements and new
details for players to discover plus the
current community of ps3 players and
Xbox 360 players will have the ability
to transfer their GTA online progress
and characters to the PlayStation 4
not done yet another game that I get the
honor of sharing with you tonight is
from the acclaimed studio Rocksteady and
publishing giant Warner Brothers please
take a look
Bruce I found penguin he's got a weapons
cache on the north end of Mia Gotti
islands the area is heavily protected by
the Arkham Knights drone forces - be
careful
I'm on my way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
running Diagnostics thermal imaging
shows our life takes our unmanned and
controlled remotely you're clear to
engage weapon systems online be careful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do we do about the man my man don't
worry about that man he's about to
become extinct
not a rich look at it all
lovely lovely money and it's oh ma oh
the Arkham Knight dog
so that's silly at
[Applause]
I'll need more bones would you crush how
many lives will you destroy in pursuit
of what you call justice you are the
product of everything you fear violence
helplessness all that remains is for you
to watch as I drag your beloved Gotham
into oblivion
spectacular and even more smoke than at
the EI press conference
Batman Arkham Knight on PlayStation 4
will be amazing and comes with scarecrow
nightmare missions that are only
available on PlayStation PlayStation
remains steadfast in our commitment to
provide gamers the thrills deep
narrative experiences and challenging
gameplay they desire our team of
creative minds is passionate about doing
one thing better than anyone else
creating the best place to play I'd like
to leave you with one last title from
one of the finest Studios in the world
that captures the very best of the
PlayStation spirit thank you all so much
and have a wonderful evening
[Applause]
[Applause]
so what do you think it's a lot to take
end kid where do I even start
you've been out of the game for a long
time maybe I need to remind you the kind
of people we'd be crossing here slowly I
know the risks but come on it's a
surefire plan yeah if there's one thing
I've learned in all these years it's
there's no such thing as a surefire plan
I don't really have an option here you
know that
[Music]
yeah maybe you're right I've been out of
the game I need back in so can I count
on you
[Music]
one last time
I could
let's go do it
one last time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]